sur la place darcy à dijon l'hôtel du
nord l'un des plus anciens
établissements de la ville à sa tête il
y a deux ministres à chaud en ce moment
le theux liée à une préoccupation la
mise aux normes d'accessibilité
la partie a censuré et finit par contre
la réception n'est obligé de refaire une
réception qui ne soit pas
discriminatoire par rapport aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
donc on est obligé de mettre une caisse
à hauteur de je crois 70 60 cm enfin
j'ai parlé centimes est exact n'allez
pas lui dire qu'il ne se soucie pas des
handicaps et son frère et lui même en
fauteuil et la famille c'est sacré chez
les fera chaud il gère l'hôtel depuis
quatre générations
aujourd'hui avec un taux d'occupation de
65 %
les 27 chambres seules ou plutôt bien
enfin les 26 chambres puisqu'une d'entre
elles va bientôt se transformer en
toilettes pour handicapés
toutes les lois tous les textes social
fiscal juridique ça change tous les six
mois ou tous les atouts le tous les ans
alors que nos investissements sont des
investissements à 7 8 10 ans voire plus
donc on est obligé de faire marcher sous
les ondées mars une course de formule 1
et on sait pas si on aura le droit de
changer les pneus au chant de remettre
de l'essence
c'est exactement la même chose donc le
problème est grave comme pour les
handicapés y aurait tout ça c'est un
dossier qui représente tout ce qu'il a
fallu faire pour essayer de mettre aux
normes et on n'y est pas encore ça m'a
coûté 250 mille euros depuis 24 ans
l'hôtel du nord n'est plus indépendant
et est rattachée à une franchise des
franchises qui prennent de plus en plus
de place sur le marché entre 2012 et
2017 le nombre d'hôtels de chaîne est
passée de 3200 à 3400 dans le même temps
les indépendances ont passé eux deux 13
mille deux cents à douze mille neuf cent
pour comprendre cette évolution nous
nous rendons dans cet hôtel du centre
historique
christophe conte a repris
l'établissement il y à 12 ans de 24
chambres
il est passé à 27 car pour maintenir son
bénéfice stable
il doit augmenter son chiffre d'affaires
on a une concurrence dernier demi comme
tout le monde le sait
donc sur dijon on a énormément
énormément de chambre de particuliers
qui maintenant louent leurs appartements
comme un professionnel
sauf qu'eux ne sont pas soumis aux
charges que nous non au contre un
tournoi que nous on peut avoir
et puis le deuxième point c'est que vous
avez aussi une part de plus en plus
importante de réservation booking qui
font l'objet d'une commission de 10 7%
par par réservation
la concurrente des logements d'airbnb
les commissions des agences de voyages
en ligne comme booking
il y a de quoi rebuter ceux qui
souhaiteraient se lancer mais le marché
reste attractif en bourgogne franche
comté par exemple malgré un léger recul
l'année dernière il reste plus de sept
millions deux cent treize mille nuitées
à se partager dans la périphérie de
chalon sur saône ces dernières années
les hôtels de chaînes ont poussé comme
des champignons
pourtant à farine il y a cinq ans un
couple de franciliens est venu reprendre
cet hôtel si grégoire travaillait déjà
dans l'hôtellerie en salariés pour un
ellis est une première expérience ce
soir pour elle c'est cuisine n'est pas
que je suis plus que multitâche je fais
de la réception du téléphone de la
communication du marketing de la
gouvernance du ce après deux premières
années difficiles il commence à
améliorer leur rentabilité
pour obtenir des prix sur les achats de
fournitures et faciliter leur promotion
ils ont intégré un groupement
d'hôteliers indépendants une façon de
réaliser des économies d'échelle comme
le font les grandes chaînes aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression qu'ils font pour vivre
viol j'espère que la tendance changera
vraiment que que dans l'esprit des gens
voilà l'indépendant la proximité ça son
importance et qu'il faut la poule à
préserver l'authenticité meilleurs
atouts pour résister à l'avenir c'est le
pari des indépendants si aujourd'hui il
représente toujours 80% des
établissements
il ne concentre plus que la moitié des
chambres d'hôtels en france